on parle avec vous de ce projet d'hyper
centre pour l'agglomération pour la
ville de Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est le
quartier je disais autour de la gare de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines est-ce qu'on
peut dire que depuis la création de la
ville nouvelle dans les années 70 on a
pas vu pareil projet d'aménagement sur
sur l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines alors c'est vrai que c'est un
projet extrêmement important puisque on
va toucher aux espaces urbains on va
toucher aussi à des bâtiments à des
bâtiments emblématiques comme celui qui
fait le qui entoure la place de la gare
comme la scène nationale également donc
il va y avoir une transformation
absolument colossale qui s'ajoute à la
transformation aux travaux que la gare
SNCF a réalisé est en train de terminer
à leur terme et qui là aussi c'est 43
millions d'euros de travaux et c'est
l'un des plus gros chantiers
d'Île-de-France donc tout ça mis
ensemble effectivement ça fait un projet
absolument prodigieux mais qui était
absolument nécessaire c'est un
aménagement l'hyper centre qui date des
années 80 et donc il y avait vraiment
nécessité aujourd'hui de de changer de
le transformer il faut se souvenir que
ce quartier le quartier de la gare c'est
c'est la porte d'entrée de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est la
première image que beaucoup de gens
peuvent avoir lorsqu'ils arrivent sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et aujourd'hui ça n'est pas forcément
une image très compréhensible ou en tout
cas très représentatif de ce qu'on peut
avoir sur le territoire et donc c'est là
où il fallait qu'on puisse mettre en
adéquation ce qui existe sur le
territoire toutes les toutes les
qualités tous les potentiels que nous
avons sur 50 ans en Yvelines et à
Montigny bien sûr de pouvoir les
présenter dans ce quartier là que les
gens comprennent tout de suite là où ils
arrivent donc le projet était lancé
officiellement en 2019 il y a eu
différentes phases de concertation avec
un début de travaux dès cette année vous
en parliez sur splato même c'était en
janvier dernier et on le disait
différents secteurs concernés alors on
parle de l'hyper centre ça va de la gare
au théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines et
aussi les quais François Lequet François
Truffaut mais différents secteurs
concernés avec aussi différentes phases
d'aménagement oui absolument alors vous
le disiez ça a démarré en 2019 et quand
on y pense quand on voit
l'importance du secteur des secteurs
concernés se dire que les travaux
débutent simplement cinq ans plus tard
c'est prodigieux et là-dessus moi je
tiens encore à remercier les services de
la Communauté d'Agglomération parce
qu'il y a eu un travail fantastique
c'est un quartier compliqué avec des
divisions en volume des copropriétés des
choses vraiment difficiles et menées à
tambour battant tout ce travail là c'est
une vraiment une grande réussite l'autre
grande réussite pour moi c'est que ce
travail là il a été fait en concertation
avec les habitants et donc le projet on
l'a dit le dernier il date des années 80
40 ans donc on imagine l'échelle de
temps qu'aura le prochain aménagement et
bien il sera le fruit de la concertation
avec les habitants et ça c'est une vraie
fierté donc il y a tout cet aménagement
tout se réaménagement même autour de la
gare de saint-quent en ligne vous l'avez
dit la destruction de l'anneau rouge ça
va débuter cette année et ça va
permettre d'ouvrir cette place de la
gare et oui parce que ça c'est le la
tendance des années 80 c'était de
construire les choses refermées sur
elle-même et
ce qui fait quand vous arrivez sur la
place de la garde de Montigny vous ne
savez pas où vous êtes vous ne savez pas
où se trouve la ville demain il s'agit
de l'ouvrir complètement il faut se
rappeler aussi qu'il y a un autre atout
nous sommes dans un milieu extrêmement
urbain avec une mixité fonctionnelle
très importante un million de mètres
carrés de de bureau une université avec
plus de 15000 étudiants une scène
nationale un centre commercial régional
du logement et bien d'autres choses
encore et au cœur de tout ça la nature
qui démarre de l'autre côté de l'avenue
du loisirs qui n'est pas loin donc c'est
vrai que ça c'est unique on a eu cette
chance fabuleuse d'avoir cette
opportunité sur le territoire et donc il
fallait ouvrir la place de la gare
d'abord pour une meilleure compréhension
mais aussi pour je disais à l'instant
montrer ce quel territoire le territoire
ce n'est pas que du béton c'est la
nature et la nature on l'a quand on sort
de la gare désormais on le verra mais ça
laissera place à de nouveaux projets il
y a eu l'inauguration l'été dernier de
l'immeuble native c'est ça avec d'autres
aussi projets qui vont qui vont voir le
jour là on est sur le secteur de la
guerre on va se de passer sur un autre
point important ce qui est la place
Pompidou celle du théâtre de 50 ans en
Yvelines et là aussi il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont prévues oui puisque on
va complètement transformer cette place
d'abord dans la façon de circuler des
voitures puisque aujourd'hui vous avez
des voix absolument dans tous les sens
et donc c'est plus une place routière
qu'une place dédiée dédiée aux piétons
alors que c'est un centre-ville donc
demain nous allons simplifier et réduire
le nombre de voix présentes sur la place
Pompidou pour rendre ces espaces au
piétons remettre des espaces verts sur
la place Pompidou parce qu'il manque
aujourd'hui créer de la vie en
agrandissant les terrasses des des cafés
des restaurants qui sont nombreux et
puis aussi en lien avec la scène
nationale donner un espace devant la
scène nationale pour pouvoir proposer
demain des spectacles en les murs je
suis une extension du Théâtre national
il y a également une extension du
théâtre effectivement qui viendra
rajouter non seulement un lieu d'accueil
à l'intérieur du théâtre mais aussi une
brasserie restaurant qui sera ouverte au
public et qui rajoutera encore un lieu
de convivialité dans de ville donc de
cette place Pompidou on descend les
marches qui sont juste à côté du Théâtre
national on arrive sur le quai François
Truffaut là aussi des aménagements
prévus des aménagements prévus et une
vraie réussite en fait aujourd'hui tout
le monde a en tête cet immense bassin et
tout autour alors il y a la partie
devant les restaurants mais le reste on
a un enchevêtrement de dalles de béton
avec différents niveaux quelque chose de
très compliqué et de et de pas très joli
demain une partie du bassin va laisser
place à des espaces verts très
importants avec des arbres plantés et
puis nous allons sur le canal et là le
canal lui aussi tout au long va être
planté ce qui fait que ce lieu
aujourd'hui très bétonné demain va se
transformer en un véritable parc urbain
et qui lui aussi sera une centralité
très importante pour le territoire donc
on voit ce projet bien sûr à l'écran on
a oublié l'avenue du centre dans tout ça
réaménagé aussi alors avec une plus
grande place donnée aux cyclistes
notamment il y a une partie cyclable un
peu plus importante absolument alors
l'idée c'était ça c'était on le sait
pour ceux qui connaissent l'avenue du du
centre on a une rangée de stationnement
de voitures non seulement de part et
d'autre mais également au milieu de la
voix demain et bien toute la partie qui
n'est plus destinée aux voitures viendra
jusqu'à cet endroit où sont situés les
voitures et il y aura des arbres des
arbustes plantés là il y aura là où
circulent les voitures aujourd'hui quand
on est face au théâtre donc sur les
voies de droite nous aurons là les
pistes cyclables et puis là aussi une
extension des terrasses avec là aussi
plantation d'espace vert tout le long de
cette voix donc des mobilités douces qui
seront confortés on pourra les
facilement à la gare on pourra
facilement partir de la gare pour se
rendre là où on souhaite aller au
Vélodrome par exemple qui n'est pas très
loin et en même temps un lieu de
convivialité là aussi avec des terrasses
pour les beaux jours donc beaucoup de
travaux probablement la compris quel est
le calendrier quand est-ce qu'on pourra
voir tous ces aménagements se terminer
alors le démarrage des travaux doit se
faire normalement la préparation du
chantier en fin de en fin d'année 2023
et le lancement des travaux en 2024 nous
attaquons d'abord par l'avenue du centre
et la place Pompidou qui dureront grosso
modo deux ans donc ça nous amène
jusqu'en 2026 et à partir de 2026 nous
aurons le quêtes Truffaut et le canal
qui prendront la suite au niveau des
travaux pour quel budget alors le
département des lignes sera à vos côtés
de 50 ans de la commune alors le budget
total est estimé autour de en parlant de
tous les projets qui sont là nous sommes
autour de 50 millions d'euros si vous
rajoutez les 43 millions de la gare vous
voyez on est presque à 100 millions sur
cette opération
donc une partie de financement par 50
ans en Yvelines bien sûr mais aussi une
partie très importante par le
département pour une raison
que vous qu'on peut comprendre très
facilement cette hyper simple je le
disais c'est la porte d'entrée de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est aussi
l'un des c'est le poumon économique un
des poumons économiques essentiels des
Yvelines et donc dans le la
redistribution des cartes qui se jouent
aujourd'hui au niveau de la région
Île-de-France avec toutes les gares qui
sont en train de se créer autour de
Paris il faut créer un lieu attractif
qui nous permet de retenir les
entreprises et c'est bien l'objectif
pour lequel le Département souhaite
s'investir massivement sur cette
opération c'est précisément pour garder
ce poumon économique essentiel sur
l'ouest de parisien donc voilà pour ce
quartier hyper centre je profite de
votre présence en plateau pour vous
poser une question liée à l'île de
loisirs on est juste à côté du quartier
hyper centre et on parlait du
département le département des villes
qui a annoncé tout récemment ce
désengager de du comité qui gère l'île
de loisirs de 50 ans de Lille on parle
du Comité Syndical comment réagit-on du
côté de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et de
l'agglomération justement à ce
désengagement du département
il se désengage du Comité Syndical il
nous l'a écrit ne se désengage pas de
son investissement et de son et de sa
présence sur l'île de loisirs simplement
d'une manière différente pour reprendre
les mots de du président du département
des Yvelines pierre-bédier un jour m'a
dit la difficulté que nous avons avec le
fonctionnement de de cette île de
loisirs c'est qu'il y en a un qui tient
le volant il y en a un qui tient levier
de vitesse et le troisième les pédales
et ça ça peut pas fonctionner donc
l'idée c'était que nous puissions
travailler avec la région 50 ans en
Yvelines et la région sur à la fois le
côté investissement et sur le côté
fonctionnement pour que ensemble nous
puissions débattre du projet apporté sur
cette île de loisirs et le département
s'est engagé à investir massivement ce
qui n'était pas de sa compétence jusque
là d'investir massivement sur les
travaux qui viendront sur l'île de
loisirs et bien sûr il jouera toujours
son rôle financier sur la partie sociale
puisque ça c'est de sa compétence sur
l'île de loisirs merci Laurent mercker
maire de Montigny-bretonneux premier
vice-président de Saint-Quentin en Y